un enfant
ça vous décroche un rêve se portent
s'élève et sa part en chantant
un enfant
avec un peu de chance se sentant de
silence et ses pleurs des diamants
[Musique]
j'accueille comment est née cette
chanson même dépanné cogitations elle
est à naître elle est honnête vous en
avez beaucoup comme ça si j'en ai c'est
est ce que vous savez d'avancé une
chanson marchera pas ce stade là il faut
se soit plus avancée que ça doit marcher
je sais si elle va me faire marcher
voilà je suppose que vraiment pas ce
qu'il faut vous laisse entier si je mens
france si je m'ennuie c'est de rentrer
expliquez vous cette connivence entre le
public et vous parce que c'est même pas
un accord cette espèce de deux jeux de
extraordinaire qui démarre dès que vous
prononcez les premières paroles la fin
vous sentez bien sûr n'ont pas bien non
ils sont tous a priori non
ensemble ça sent tout à fait autre chose
contre je trouve que c'est très centré
gonzesses quoi rené ils sont trés ça
devient très féminin la salle le public
est très féminin
ce pas j'ai l'impression dé viol est un
petit peu par moment mais ils n'ont pas
de connivence
saleh de quoi de regrets dans vie de ce
sacré différence qui entre les choses
qu'on rêve ce serait en réalisent qu'ils
ont pendant des rires et parce qu'on
n'est pas si on avait raté ça quand même
ça n'est tout ça c'est pas très triste
vous croyez alors comment triste et
nostalgique nombreux bars à chicha
surnomme j'écris pas des chansons nous
sommes mais c'est pas triste
est ce que vous êtes heureux de cette
réussite extraordinaire
maintenant vous me parler comme un gars
qui fait du cav compte en 1900 mêlant
mais j'ai réussi quoi quand je lis
rimbaud et que j'écoute le quatuor de
ravel
j'ai tout raté non plus c'est ce n'est
pas figé je ne pleure pas qu'est ce que
j'ai réussi
on ne réussit jamais que par rapport à
ce qu'on connaît comprenez ce que je
veux dire je freinais à vas-y les
mouiller en 1892
je serais très très fier et consciente
de cette magnifique réussite mais
c'est impossible d compenser un peu
voilà corner on les deux bateaux il
résout ni le quatuor de debussy voiture
doha des états unis s'est clos et puis
après j'entends chansonnette d'un gars
qui s'appelle bahreïn je trouve ça bien
ok je trouve qu'ils se prostituent pas
trop enfin je suis quand même c'est pas
vrai est il à ce métal gonflé à moucher
com/ca/fra télécom sagna ça n'est pas
très sérieux
j'ai pas honte je n'ai pas honte mais où
le repas prostitution y a pas de
prostitution ou alors c'est grave
[Musique]